el agua un recurso indispensable que año
tras año se torna más escaso en la
actualidad cerca de un cuarto de la
población mundial se encuentra en lo que
se conoce como situación de estrés
hídrica grave numerosas actividades
humanas provocan la sequía que reduce el
agua dulce del planeta regiones que
alguna vez fueron fértiles como
andalucía en el sur de españa se
transforman poco a poco en desiertos y
las tensiones entre países se hacen
notorias un ejemplo se da en torno al
río nilo fuente esencial para una decena
de países en áfrica del este la gran
presa del renacimiento lanzada en 2011
por etiopía suscita todavía inquietudes
en sudán y egipto ambos países
dependientes del río temen ver limitado
el acceso a sus aguas la misma tensión
la comparten jordán líbano israel siria
y jordania que se disputan el control
del agua mientras el río jordán se seca
y el consumo de los países aumenta
en asia la sequía del río mekong y la
multiplicación de empresas chinas
amenazan directamente a 60 millones de
habitantes en los últimos años e incluso
grandes ciudades como roma los ángeles o
ciudad del cabo se han visto amenazadas
por sequías según la onu 3600 millones
de personas viven en zonas
potencialmente pobres en agua